hey guys in this video I'm gonna show
you how to film yourself with your phone
and to do it just like a pro now when I
started my channel over two years ago I
did not have a great quality camera to
phone on my videos so the only solution
I had was to use the phone that I'm
using right now to film this video so in
this video I'm gonna give you seven my
best tips to film great quality videos
with your smart phone
let's get to it all right guys I'm not
gonna waste any of your time so let's
start with the first step
[Music]
all right now the first step is to use
natural light in fact I'm recording this
video right now with natural light now
you gotta remember never ever film
yourself with the light behind you
meaning that the camera looks towards
the light as I'm showing you right now
so all you got to do is open a door or a
window to let the light in and then
record yourself while the light shines
on your face so the camera then the
phone is right between you and the light
we've gotta adjust the video settings on
your phone it's so simple and yet so
many people never do it so open your
camera on your phone go to settings go
to videos and select the highest quality
for rear and front video size now
remember don't just go and shoot but
think a little bit what do you want to
use this video for if it's for YouTube
for example you want it to be a
landscape if it's for Facebook or
Instagram then portrait might be better
with the global tech protection and
support company as your own found that
the average person struggles to go ten
minutes without touching their phones
yeah just think about that anyway
if you use your phone every ten to
twenty minutes over and over and over
again then of course the front lens and
the rear lens they're gonna get dirty so
you got to clean it and all you got to
do is to get lint-free cloth all right
didn't breathe a little bit on the lens
like that get some moisture on it and
then you gently clean it and then your
videos will come out great
the press focus most people just take
their phones and I just press record but
your phone doesn't really know what to
focus on you need to tell it all you got
to do is to press with your finger where
you want the camera to focus on we've
changed the angles of course here it
depends on what you want to film so if
you want to do something some action or
something interesting then a lower angle
might be better to show the shot or just
a normal closer angle for a profile shot
and if you want to talk to the camera
then this height is okay you see the
angle of the camera is just a little bit
lower than my eye level around here and
it looks great and then a high angle can
also work really well to show the
setting so don't just use the same
setting but change it up a little bit to
get the perfect shot get phone
accessories there are three very
important affordable phone accessories
that will definitely help you to record
or film greater quality videos a phone
lines a tripod and this guy to put it on
a microphone and then also this guy
helps with those noises of the wind now
you can still go about the tripod you
can stack some books and record yourself
you can go about the lens but the most
important thing is a good microphone now
when I started the channel I did not
have a good quality microphone ins
people started to complain about the bad
audio if you don't believe me go back to
my first videos on this channel and you
will manage terrible anyway first I used
this shotgun mic it's really good
because it cancels all the noise behind
it and only focus on what's in front of
it and then later I got this guy over
here you can see the level ear mic I'll
add it all for any bit of description so
you can check it out
[Music]
read the last one and it is to get an
editing program you can increase the
quality of your video a lot with editing
by changing the brightness for example
adding sharpness and the right color to
your video then you can also add music
and create interesting graphics now I
learned everything that I know about
editing on YouTube so you don't have to
do a course about it just watch some
YouTube videos and then also you don't
need to buy an editing program it can
use free ones I used to use headphone
for express and there's a few others
iMovie light works blender shortcut and
more not just some last advice I'm gonna
be very very honest here
your first videos will be your worst it
will feel uncomfortable it will feel
weird to talk into a camera and I think
only when I reached 100 videos only then
I started to have more confidence and
look we all we all got to start
somewhere
so my advice to you is to just start and
as you go you will see your confidence
is growing while your experience grows
and that will give you a lot more
confidence in yourself to create more
videos and you're gonna start to see
that more creativity more ideas gonna
just come out now if you're someone that
tries to be a good person in this world
then you got to do it
you got a shiner life there's a lot of
bad influencers out there's a lot of bad
videos out there Edmund Burke said all
that is required for evil to triumph is
for good men to do nothing so as I said
it's a lot of bad stuff on social media
and we need more good to change the
world it's time to shine your light I'll
see in the next video Cheers